pas mal j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup le trou du départ c'est
très simple on va parler de tout ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
eu des nouvelles incroyable et à chaque
fois il y aura un trou dans la phrase
à vous de le combler voilà
l'élégantissime jouera avec vous bien
entendu les rayons qui est avec johnny
depp s'est fait sous fait en plus ça se
passe devant la caméra
non mais vraiment elle est bonne qu'à la
radio j'adore jouer même quand je perds
away oh là là j'allais faire tomber le
leader
merci alors première phrase
johnny depp c'est fait c'est fait
pendant quatorze ans et parfois même la
nuit
valérie bonnet gdf s'est fait harceler
pendant 14 ans et parfois même la nuit
non on rappelle johnny depp bien sûr
qu'est le pirate des caraïbes aux effets
bien sûr et moi je suis johnny de dieppe
oui les tony's est c'est fait épiler le
site pendant 14 tours devenait trop cher
on va venir les podiums il faudra bien
qu'on voit c'est fait quoi tout le monde
en a parlé carolis et étiez non
est ce que est ce que est ce que notre
notre ryan gosling du public a une idée
qu'elle est la question
belle affiche et merci salut dans le
passé je crois que c'est le fils
d'isabelle oui j'aime avait piraté son
téléphone bravo johnny depp
oui s'est fait piraté pendant 14 ans et
parfois même la nuit c'est une histoire
de ont fait qu'ils arrivent à johnny
depp
le pirate les pulsars ailleurs file ap
le mec il va passer plus de temps au
tribunal quand on avril n'arrête pas
après son divorce qui a été chaotique et
qui nous a rappelé les heures les plus
hauts avec amber heard ou amber voilà l
acteur s'attaque aujourd'hui au journal
the sun
oui le journal de bernard montiel le
soleil pour la seconde fois en quelques
mois cette fois-ci jaune il aime affirme
le tabloïd anglais a piraté son
téléphone pendant 14 ans le seuil où le
but de ce piratage aurait été de publier
des informations personnelles de
l'acteur regardez vous explique ce truc
de fou qui va faire peur parce que vous
je pense qu'à mon avis
journal de mickey à pirater votre c'est
une information à peine croyable que
semble détenir johnny depp contre la
rédaction du magazine anglais the sun un
tabloïd très décrié pour ses méthodes
parfois un peu musclée pour obtenir des
informations si on sait qu'ils payent
régulièrement des proches et des
informateurs pour obtenir et publier des
infos privées sur les personnalités
cette fois ci l'acteur a décidé
d'attaquer le titre de presse pour une
méthode encore plus grave
les écoutes téléphoniques selon lui
durant 14 ans le journal aurait mis son
téléphone sur écoute dans le but de
publier dans son journal des
informations exclusives sur la vie de
l'acteur c'est avec cette technique
totalement inégal que la rédaction
république et à deux reprises en exclu
mondiale l'information des deux
grossesses de vanessa paradis
sa compagne de l'époque mais aussi des
infos personnelles sur l'état de santé
de lily rose lorsqu'elle avait sept ans
des faits très graves s'ils étaient
avérés j'ai pas du tout écouter le truc
mais j'écoute la musique
alors si c'est vrai c'est grave montre
ça je suis sûr que vous réagissez de
pula dessus soit sur les réseaux sur
johnny depp le pauvre c'est des méthodes
honnêtement qu'on connaît qui sont
employés partout dans le monde
non il faut en moyenne il faut à peu
près 30 minutes tu reviens chez vous
pour vous piratez de tout donc
aujourd'hui il ya plein de gens qui ont
été créés été espionnés moi je le sais
parce que même chez moi une certaine
époque quand j'étais dans un certain
divorce
monsieur rendu compte qu'ils avaient on
ne m'a posé des débats bien sûr c'est ça
va extrêmement vite pour que vous ayez
un band qu'un petit bois un petit
boîtier tout sort de la maison et alors
je connais quelques photographes qui
font des photos interdites si elle
arrive se gênent pas ils ont des infos
comment comme ça ils payent ils ont des
infos par la police ils ont des infos
par les compagnies aériennes
et ils vont toutes les infos qu'il faut
avoir un vrai problème effectivement ils
sont malins mais je vous dis que c'est
ça se fait très souvent et très
régulièrement oui c'est qu'il a pris un
avocat de ce problème
slave excité l'avocat de lady di et
d'elton john est il le seul est suspecté
plus que suspects et parce qu'ils
avaient déjà eu des procès pour le même
journal qu'ils avaient déjà payé des
dizaines de millions de dollars pour
éviter le procès donc reconnaissant
implicitement qu'il y fait 4 8 pirates
et 1200 savez comme disait john john
dont let the sun go down le shérif
deuxième trou tu peux pas là attention
regardez
vg
il a sorti ça et se fait défoncer vg
dream donc celui qui chantait bien sûr
est celui qui chante ramener la coupe à
la maison
allez les bleus
[Musique]
alors est-ce que ça a pas que le nom du
groupe
mais j'ai dream qui veut dire rêve
végétarien sorti sa carotte
non vous m'avez pas l'aider merci mme
ellen v gdim a sorti sa marque de
vêtements non illégaux l'élégante ici je
sais pas du tout chez pas du tout
synphot ils ont passé mais j'ai les
crocs un programme bêta riera à quoi
exciter un truc tu vois pas à la moyenne
des deux journalistes et 35 ans bien sûr
oui oui je suis rhubarbe et s amuse tout
cas ça oui
du coup est-ce qu'il a sorti un nouveau
titre et se fait défoncer sortie salle
chossat chambas à sa nouvelle chanson
toi pompe et naïm avoir pompé l'eau qui
voudraient encore marché de flex et la
bouche
vg dream a sorti sa nouvelle chanson et
il s'est fait défoncer le pauvre vg
dream à chaque gros gros événement il
sort un gros sont apparemment cette fois
ci c'est le des compliments qu'il a
voulu fêter avec un nouveau son vg dream
sur twitter elle a publié plusieurs
vidéos ou longtemps ce morceau est
derrière il s'est fait fracasser
regardez
[Musique]
et ici les fracasser mais ça rappelle
beaucoup y aura de la compagnie
vg dream qui parle quand il fait
toujours le nom c'est bien je vais
sortir de la maison
ainsi prenez un taxi
salut chez lui ça lui aurait
sérieusement sentir du coût final est
annoncé sans génie mais ça m'arrive est
là mais la coupe du monde et après on
fait sa technique ses doses répétées des
chaussures des chaussures des chaussures
des chaussures des chaussures d
exceptionnel qui fait ça la boule à
jamais j'aimerais manger le pont qui
s'est fait défoncer ce courage là dessus
mais bon ça fait énormément réagir mais
c'est un mec sympa oui c'est vrai c'est
assez rare d'être végétarien et rappeur
les chéris ça c'est fait qui dit
n'importe quoi
troisième trou du pipole allez vous
aimez le détrousser mais le pitois nous
arriver cette séquence des acteurs les
acteurs de bb à l'inrap est oui
[Musique]
les allées regardiez mais bien sûr je
t'ai vous êtes vous identifier à quel
jeu préféré dylan j'ai fait pas du tout
brandon à brandon stéphanie vous émettez
le rebelle toi bats comme lorenzo lamas
ce lorenzo la rage de voir le rebelle
dont berline c'est pas nous c'est pas
non plus booba fait tranquille toi quand
tu disais un rebelle tombé vers l'iss ça
va c'est mignon les acteurs de beloeil
berline seraient tous seraient tous les
criminels pas très sympa vraiment que je
devenu naturiste devenu naturiste non
gelée eu d'accord vous êtes vous dit
pourquoi ils cherchent caroline
ithurbide ruiné de l'escalier en fait on
dit qu'ils sont tous me dit je crois
exactement alors c'est vraiment une
histoire assez folle c'est l'histoire
d'une malédiction qui tous les acteurs
de la série mythique beverly hills 90210
les villes à la dernière tragédie au
gâteau c'est bien sûr la mort de leur
père et mars 2019
bien sûr qu'il est décédé des suites
d'un avc machine à 52 ans mais c'est
loin d'être le seul acteur de la série
avoir été touché par la malédiction
connaissait tous beverly hills à l'usagé
les plus jeunes
et regardez il y à une malédiction
autour de cette série
regardez c'est ouf non mais franchement
ça fait flipper ça fait ça fait flipper
ça fait de la peine
et moi je crois ça moi je le jure que
c'est vrai pas moins drôle et maudit moi
quoi je crois au lieu maudit comme vous
ai compris
[Rires]
si vous êtes un grand fan des séries des
années 90 ou 2000 vous devez déjà savoir
que les stars de votre adolescence vont
pas toujours une vie privée aussi
agréable que leur exploit à l'écran et
quand on fait la liste des acteurs de
ces séries qui ont eu des problèmes
on pourrait même penser qu'il s'agit là
d'une malédiction prenez shannen doherty
la comédienne qui s'est glisse
durant des années dans la peau de brenda
dans la série beverly hills en 2015 elle
apprenait qu'elle était atteinte d'un
cancer du sein une maladie dont elle est
toujours victime à l'heure actuelle
problèmes de santé également pour kelly
taylor dans la série qui a découvert il
ya quelques temps être atteinte d'une
pathologie cardiaque et ça n'est pas
tout car les acteurs de beverly hills
sont nombreux à avoir été atteint par
cette malédiction en 2002 jason
priestley alias brandon walsh est
victime d'un accident de la route qui
lui brisera la colonne vertébrale et une
partie du crâne
il n'y a pas que le casting de beverly
hills qui semblait trop touchés par
cette mystérieuse série d'accidents du
côté de dawson les acteurs ne sont pas
non plus épargnés on peut évoquer par
exemple l'actrice michelle williams dont
l'ex compagnon est mort d'une overdose
accidentelle de médicaments en 2008 ou
encore katie holmes ex de tom cruise qui
se bat aujourd'hui contre la
scientologie qui souhaitent la
déposséder de son enfant autant de
destins brisés qui laisse penser que les
mauvais esprits ne sont pas très clients
des séries des années 90
[Musique]
sarthou rente année j'adore a vu sa
taille du tueur dansante
par contre toi tu es d'humeur un tel
chiffre alors oui puisque vous avez
porté atteinte à ma dignité de
journalistes juste avant jeudi a précisé
qu'en mai complète maudit et naturistes
s'est fait connaître pour être
journaliste et au pôle emploi les choses
passées l'été vous allez savoir ce que
sa miss france se fait salement miss
france comment s'appelle miss france
d'ailleurs en ce moment tino bottineau
exactement est vrai les meilleurs en
miss france quand géopolitique miss
france se fait salement assez horrible
ce fait salement bottineau oui on fait
salement recaler d'un buffalo grill se
fait salement recalé à buffalo grill
tuque à vous c'est peut-être votre
émission de l'année non vraiment ce
faire socialement quoi c'est faire ça
ils m'ont insulté salma insulter c'est
un peu ça à les critiquer je prends
benhaim pour son sixième point alors
qu'il n'y a eu que quatre ici les rêves
de pas mal mais ça qu'on s'est fait
insulter clémence bottineau qui a été
miss france 2000 vendée en décembre
dernier mais qui n'a salah al a été élue
miss france sera mauvais a dit non mais
la cour a vraiment et on n'aura pas vu
de l'année elle n'aura pas vu de l'année
elle a pas mangé une tranche de
saucisson dans une guerre non mais ça
rigolait pas ça la lune non messieurs
la pauvre alors juste ici souple on lève
la main c'est par williams à miliciens
les parents du concours et ben vous
allez voir vous allez voir comparaison
sur le voyage sur les voyages tu as
raison elle a pensé qu'elle allait faire
un tour du moins qu'elle avait voyagé
partout en france et puis elle est
restée dans un appartement ici me choque
c'est pas parce que c'est miss france
qu'elle a des paroles a été confiné
comme tout le monde elle était chez elle
avec la couronne comme ça en plus je les
adore elle est très belle et elle était
très sympathique clémence
moi j'ai envie de 2,2 laisser clémence
une année de plus voilà mairesse avec
tina maze et verizon mises à germer
donnée de faire durer son élection plus
on sort n'aurait pas de miss france elle
reste on est deuxième elles sont comme
ça enfin qui fouillade et quand elle ne
peut pas l'autre ben je regardais c'est
comme vous lls durban nommé en 2006 a
été mis jeudi à bas un jour elle a pas
pu aller au congrès du couscous et ben
c'est fatima des jacquards des histoires
2003 on se regarde l'avenir c'est que
clémence boutinot n'aura pas eu beaucoup
de chance seulement trois mois après
avoir remporté la fameuse couronne du
concours miss france le pays a été
confiné et elle n'a pas pu profiter de
son règne sauf qu'au moment où le
gouvernement a annoncé le confinement
obligatoire de tous les français elle se
trouvait en guadeloupe dans sa famille
impossible donc pour elle de rentrée
c'est donc il ya quelques jours
seulement avec la levée du confinement
que la jeune femme a pu regagner paris
pour reprendre son activité sauf que
voilà
suite à l'annoncé de ce retour certains
internautes se sont montrés critiques
dont elle peut prendre l'avion alors que
des français expatriés sont bloqués quel
intérêt il ya je pense d'autres
préoccupations que miss france mais on
n'a pas le droit d'aller plus loin de
100 km si je me trompe pas des
techniques très vite démonter par sylvie
tellier
si la question des expatriés ne se pose
pas étant donné que la guadeloupe est
française pour ce qui est des
déplacements la présidente du comité
miss france a expliqué vous êtes
nombreux à nous demander pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle rende clémence de guadeloupe et
bien parce que aujourd'hui clément salée
elle est salariée de l'organisation miss
france son travail est ici à paris
décidément cette année de miss ne
commence pas sous les meilleurs auspices
et oued avait une histoire de miss
france - chine à sa hauteur
non mais enfin ça me fait de la peine
moi j'aime bien michel jadot très
sympathique ouais nan franchement oui
ouais tu m'as se laisser déranger le
fais pas tu chanteras tarder papier au
web et d'animaux non mais je voulais
participer je suis à vos côtés de tous à
chaque instant cyril lâchent pas ne vous
et moi on est comme ça et je sais je
sais d'echery le magazine public il
affiche cyril lignac et sa copine en
titre ont en route vers quoi hervé
donnard lui et non au mariage les vues
en route vers une tartiflette vers
l'avenir vers une prime les mules a eu
quand on répond que qu'on ait su ou pas
oui ah bah je sois sûr bref vous n'avez
plus répondre de toutes les villes a eu
une à côté de la fosse et une sur vous
alors dès le mariage non alors en route
vers quoi d'allemagne vers le mariage ou
le pacs ou non pas tout à fait ça c'est
le on parle bien des cuisiniers en titre
ont en route vers le marchand piot mais
le nom
c'est tellement triste mais pas sûr on
s'en doute faire quoi il a alors nommé
dit non c'est vrai que vous en route
vers le mariage très bon et ça eh oui si
lui l'action route vers le mariage mais
avec qui avec quoi que ça comment bah
oui vous allez être en route je te jure
pour une société c'est à dire tu vas
voir tu vas on va y ouvrir une chaîne
expressément pourtant regardez
l'histoire de samia haut ça me passionne
c'est petit gossip par avoir un
franchement gars est lui aussi hommage à
des races aussi
[Rires]
avec le confinement cyril lignac est
redevenu un visage fort de la télévision
avec sa présence quotidienne depuis sa
cuisine pour préparer des plats avec les
français il a prouvé qu'il était
toujours très populaire il est en plus
leur propriétaire de plusieurs
restaurants renommés et cyril lignac a
décidément le vent en poupe
une période qui cotait vie publique
comme vie privée semble se passer pour
le mieux après avoir été en couple avec
sophie marceau et mélanie doutey l'un
des cuisiniers les plus populaires de
france est aujourd'hui avec deborah une
parfaite inconnue mais avec qui les
choses semblent se passait très bien si
l'on en croit la une du magazine public
selon le journal les deux tourtereaux
serait même sur le point de se marier
alors quand aura lieu l'événement
va-t-il l'annoncé ou garder cette
information secrète cyril lignac sera
t'il responsable du buffet autant de
questions dont on attend les réponses je
suis sait pas pour vous ou avec la
manette ou les jantes en alliage et
foutent rien su dans la danse ce tir et
ouais je sais pas où ils ont trouvé
cette ville je veux que ça je suis
rattaché au touche à tout âge à toul a
eu alors et c'est beau ça franchement
bien sûr c'est un tombeur alors les
meufs locales et les milieux l'allemagne
les meufs le canada deborah magnifique
on peut l'avoir complété sa s'est pas
débarrassé cyril lignac
on l'a pas à ma mère si bad a montré ses
limites avec cyril lignac on le connaît
comme des maillons nouveau né non mais
c'est vrai bravo car ta carrière
celui-ci si jamais le dernier pour
sortir son piment d'espelette les cherry
et pour le bien de certaines personnes
ouais
patrick bruel à vis des noms mais il a
fait il a fait un truc exceptionnel très
sec à la raison et non son compte encore
de son temps ouais son compte en banque
un gros montant sans milou à louey waouh
patrick bruel que j'aime énormément qui
est exceptionnel cependant le
confinement patrick vraiment regarder
l'histoire d'ailleurs c'est
l'anniversaire de patrick aujourd'hui
lénine même jour que mon fils parce
qu'ils ont le même âge
wii party de noël pendant le confinement
pour divertir ses fans et leur faire du
bien et faisait régulièrement des petits
concerts sur les raisons ayant profité
toujours pour lancer des appels aux dons
à ses fans et en fait au bout du truc
il avait gagné 100 mille euros 97 me
roux et patrick le dernier jour le
dernier lors du dernier l'aï donnée eh
ben il a doublé la somme il a ni donc
cent mille euros de sa poche très très
beau geste sympathique qui a fait un
très beau don et patrick que j'embrasse
très très fort effet nabila et il va
très bien il était un petit peu voilà il
va très bien où la vue sur ces life et
des lives fantastique et c'est un amour
de mec vraiment c'est vrai un vrai vrai
pote vous le savez je n'ai encore vu
mais je les croise il ya deux jours on
s'est croisé un feu rouge chevelure
clairay et à patrick bauwen j'étais en
vo je vois les batteries gouaille et là
je tape pas sa vie qui croyais que
j'étais de la maréchaussée jamais si tu
croises et pas j'ai croisé patrimoine
d'évasion discute pas eu débat commence
à matt waller j'ai dit aux 40 ans tu
t'es toujours pas questionner glee puis
à la fin il est parti base end comme
rendez vous dans ces sur rtl qu'il a dit
merci et puis il faut pas critiquer les
gens qu'il y ait des gens qui disent oui
oui c'est facile à d'argent non il ya
beaucoup d'argent qui donne pas un gros
bravo patrick voilà l'analyse mais c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime profondément il le
sait et c'est un ami voire à croître dès
qu'on a beau en huit ans vous direz vous
l'artiste moi parce que je connais
toutes ses chansons par coeur a pas
trouvé ça va lui faire et leur place
[Rires]
comptant la patrie klein et si ça allait
pas bien tu connais toute mission aller
dernier et dernier trou euh derniers
trous des millions de fans attendent
avec impatience la date de sortie de
jean michel maire de la date de sortie
de quoi date de sortie non 2 2 il ya
quelqu'un qui me dit du prochain babybel
non valérie bénaïm de quoi il ya une c
c'est quelque chose entre ont de quoi
y'a un truc qui a été reportée pendant
le convoiement c'était la sortie sur
plateforme de friends oui elle est là
les allées franches aux ailes bravo
isabelle excellons isabelle morasse
upatou c'est quoi exactement
l'assemblée se dit pas de bêtise c'est
que les gens attendent la date de sortie
sur plateforme de friends est ce que ce
n'est pas tout après qu'elle a dit c'est
une bonne réponse merci valérie vécu
quelques semaines des millions de
personnes aux états unis et dans le
monde attendait le retour de friends
vous avez dit rizzo la série mythique ne
va enfin revenir pour un tournage
spéciale avec tous les acteurs pour la
première fois depuis seize ans et
valérie merci de cette info parce que
regarder la sortie avait été repoussé à
cause du confinement c'est qu'il avait
mal voilà mais ça y est on a enfin la
date de cet épisode très particulier
regardez vous qui ne sachiez peu là
dessus et rodez
alors que les millions de fans à travers
la planète attendait désespérément un
retour de la série friends la plateforme
de vidéos ex bio match qui a racheté les
droits a décidé de réaliser un nouvel
épisode totalement inédit
seize ans après l'arrêt de la série une
annonce faite il ya plusieurs mois et
qui depuis entre certains fans qui se
demande quand est-ce que cet épisode
sera disponible
une date que la société et du bio vient
de fournir la chaîne a précisé que le
tournage avait été décalée en raison du
court aux navires us c'est donc en
juillet prochain que le tournage devrait
se dérouler un tournage qui devrait
permettre une diffusion de cet épisode
spécial quelques mois plus tard
alors encore un peu de patience après
avoir attendu 16 ans les fans sont
presque au bout du tunnel
carla
merci je connais les paroles aux
sunshine et il y en a il est dans un
sale état ainsi tourner en juillet il a
pas beaucoup de temps pour se reprendre
en main
vous avez quasiment sdf c'est lui tu
paies jean muller voilà je mets toutes
péri tu perds immersive où il est
les lignes pdf 6 et un nouveau rideau me
permettre il y en a qui en salle et de
ceux qui tuent péri parce qu'il ya une
limite au vert c'est vrai oui c'est un
bon je vous rajoute un point valérie
lemaire cachet de 2 millions d'heures
par internet
c'est l'argent je ne vois que de
regarder même s'il n'a plus d'argent
nuit est respectée puisque pour pleurer
il est quand même contente